Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
With today's graphics technology, we can enjoy
many really smooth videos that were created
using 60 frames per second.
We love it too, and we hope that you noticed
that our last hundred or maybe even more episodes
have been available in 60hz.
However, it oftentimes happens that we're
given videos that have anything from 20 to
30 frames per second.
This means that if we play them on a 60 fps
timeline, half or even more of these frames
will not provide any new information.
As we try to slow down the videos for some
nice slow-motion action, this ratio is even
worse, creating an extremely choppy output
video.
Fortunately, there are techniques that are
able to guess what happens in these intermediate
frames and give them to us.
This is what we call frame interpolation.
We have had some previous experiments in this
area where we tried to create an amazing slow
motion version of a video with some bubbles
merging.
A simple and standard way of doing frame interpolation
is called frame blending, which is a simple
averaging of the closest two known frames.
The more advanced techniques are optical flow-based,
which is a method to determine what motions
happened between the two frames, and create
new images based on that knowledge, leading
to higher quality results in most cases.
This technique uses a convolutional neural
network to accomplish something similar, but
in the end, it doesn't give us an image, but
a set of convolution kernels.
This is a transformation that is applied to
the previous and the next frame to produce
the intermediate image.
It is not the image itself, but a recipe of
how to produce it, if you will.
We've had a ton of fun with convolutions earlier,
where we used them to create beautiful subsurface
scattering effects for translucent materials
in real time, and our more loyal Fellow Scholars
remember that at some point, I also pulled
out my guitar and showed what it would sound
like inside a church using a convolution-based
reverberation technique.
The links are available in the video description,
make sure to check them out!
Since we have a neural network over here,
it goes without saying that the training takes
place on a large number of before-after image
pairs, so that the network is able to produce
these convolution kernels.
Of course, to validate this algorithm, we
also need to have access to a ground truth
reference to compare against - we can accomplish
this by withholding some information about
a few intermediate frames so we have the true
images which the algorithm would have to reproduce
without seeing it.
Kinda like giving a test to a student when
we already know the answers.
You can see such a comparison here.
And now, let's have a look at these results!
As you can see, they are extremely smooth,
and the technique retains a lot of high-frequency
details in these images.
The videos also seem temporally coherent,
which means that it's devoid of the annoying
flickering effect where the reconstruction
takes place in a way that's a bit different
in each subsequent frame.
None of that happens here, which is an excellent
property of this technique.
The python source code for this technique
is available and is free for non-commercial
uses.
I've put a link in the description, if you
have given it a try and have some results
of your own, make sure to post them in the
comments section or our subreddit discussion.
The link is available in the description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!